the gyro can experience one of the
things that they talked about in Black
Elk was the practice of the Ghost Dance
the this idea that they were going to
somehow or another bring back the old
ways and it's a sad sad story yeah when
you hear them talk about it especially
because it's coming from the words of
Black Elk who was a guy that was there
with the Battle of Little Bighorn and
then from then now is an older man
talking about what his experiences have
been like haven't had seen his people
moved to reservations and seen basically
every single treaty broken I mean was
there a single treaty that the United
States had with the Indians that it
didn't break mm-hm that would that's
insane
I mean every single one and most
treaties had some similar language a lot
of them talked about they had bad man
provisions so bad man provisions were
basically if our men the us if our men
come in and to your jurisdiction and do
something bad we'll take care of it for
you you know just some simple provisions
like that but that never was enforced
the u.s. let let their people come in
and take over what we're supposed to be
protective areas of land and and that
was just constant that happened that
happened everywhere so there were bad
man provisions there were a lot of
provisions a lot of beautiful provisions
that that tribes still talk about today
you know as as long as the the grass
grows and you know we'll have our lands
and and none of these provisions were
ever upheld and a lot of the East Coast
tribes there their boundaries were
changed and new treaties were made and
accepted and and Removal happened in and
there were new treaties and nothing was
ever maintained where did you grow up
did you grow up in Oklahoma Oklahoma you
grew up on a reservation
so Oklahoma is an interesting case so
Oklahoma did have set aside land so
Choctaw had their area Chickasaw and the
other tribes that were removed to
Oklahoma and by the way because of that
removal their tribes that were already
there were removed so there were already
tribes there the Caddo and Comanche and
other other tribes that this was already
their land so new tribes moved in and
land during the hmm I'm forgetting my
dates now but there was a commission
around 1906 or so where there was a
census and individual Indians were
allotted about a hundred and sixty acres
apiece and this was an effort to
decrease the amount of land base that
tribes held in common right and this
happened all across the country not just
in Oklahoma where there were allotment
policies and I believe there there were
about heck I'm not good with numbers I
think there were like 19 million acres
that that were removed this way of land
but what happened today there is a
criminal case before the Supreme Court
that is actually addressing these issues
because even though our lands were
allotted the exterior boundaries of our
reservations the area that we had agreed
to live in they've never been
extinguished they've never been
diminished and so the Supreme Court says
act Supreme Court is actually looking at
this issue now as to whether we still
have jurisdiction within the exterior
boundaries of our reservations in
Oklahoma would that extend to cities
those are other cities in Oklahoma that
are in those areas now yeah
now so if you think of our Tulsa yeah
so--that's Creek nation so Tulsa would
be owned well so not necessarily so so
it's raised a lot of fear with with
non-indians about why yeah
the Indians were taken back the land oh
my god
but what would actually happen there's a
lot of places in Indian country where
there's allotment and there's there's
non-indian individuals who have feel and
within exterior boundaries of
reservations and then individual Indians
owning feel and within the exterior
boundaries reservation land feel and so
just how you woody
no no so how you own land it's called
it's not restricted it's it's in fee you
own the title to that land right a lot
of land held by tribes is in trust or in
restricted fee so a common area land
like like let's look at them the
Onondaga Nation in in New York State
they have the exterior boundaries of
their reservation they own restricted
feel and so they own it but they can't
sell it without us permission right
trust land is similar and it's treated
the same as restricted fee but it's held
in trust so the US has more control of
of what happens on that land or has been
seen to have a little more control than
it would and just restricted fee but
within the exterior boundaries of the
reservation you can have this
checkerboarded ownership of land of
non-indians and Indians and and but that
doesn't necessarily mean that the tribe
has jurisdiction over the non-indian
feel and and the the civil and criminal
jurisdiction issues on an area of land
like that is extremely complex and
continues to be argued in the courts and
most of the time
jurisdiction most of the time we lose
those cases especially since the 80s and
90s and up until today we've there was
really a change and kind of how the
Supreme Court decided Indian law cases
so if we go back into the history of
federal Indian policy you see this kind
of weird schizophrenic you know those
those those Marshall cases that I talked
about they really set forward kind of
schizophrenic principles that the
Indians are sovereign but they're
they're just a ward and they're
uncivilized so we have to take care of
them but their sovereign and so you have
a different areas of eras of time
policymakers who who support tribal
sovereignty and we'll use those cases to
help support that sovereignty and then
there are other administration's that
come around not talking about any
current administration but that that
used those cases against us and in
degrade policy and degrade any kind of
Rights that we may have gained in in
other eras so it's it's really been you
know Indians today live in this live in
such an insecure world you know our
statistics are horrible you know the
suicide rate for our youth our high
school graduates everything that you
could possibly think of that there's a
statistic on we're usually the lowest or
the worst and it's because we live in a
society that is constantly changing we
can never depend on whether or not our
rights are secured whether or not we're
going to have land jobs be able to
practice our culture
[Applause]